За скільки продаються судді та як розкрадають
державні гроші? Про найбільш кричущі приклади
корупції в Україні розповідають українські та
німецькі активісти на безкоштовних
антикорупційних екскурсіях.
Я розповім вам про цю прекрасну будівлю.
Починають з вертолітного майданчика Януковича.
Він був протизаконно збудований на історичних
пагорбах Києва, аби екс-президент міг комфортно і,
так би мовити, з вітерцем діставатися маєтку
в Межигір’ї.
Біля Міністерства охорони здоров’я розповідають
про ще одне "диво" корупції.
Чи можете сказати, що це?
Для лікарень придбали швабри за майже
100 доларів за штуку - це вдвічі дорожче, ніж
на ринку. І це попри електронну систему
державних закупівель.
Для українців ми хочемо показати, як боротися
з корупцією і що з нею можна боротися. Адже те, що
корупція в Україні існує і в яких формах, їм
пояснювати не потрібно. А іноземцям ми хочемо
показати, що боротьба є.
Антикорупційні екскурсії досить популярні
в різних країнах світу. Українські та німецькі
активісти реалізували ідею завдяки фахівцям
з Науково-освітнього центру протидії корупції
при Києво-Могилянській академії. Мета -
привернути увагу до боротьби з корупцією.
З огляду на кількість судових рішень щодо
корупціонерів складається враження, що нічого
з часів Майдану не змінилося. Але подивіться на те,
яка кількість людей нині проти корупції бореться.
Вперше затримали на корупційних схемах
сина міністра внутрішніх справ. Ще кілька років
тому таке неможливо було уявити.
Наступна зупинка екскурсії - біля Верховного Суду.
Адже корупція - головна причина того, що лише
піввідсотка українців довіряють судам.
Суддя одного з київських судів Чаус
зберігав гроші в цій банці.
Можете сказати, скільки грошей сюди влізе?
10 тисяч.
Хто більше?
Більше! - Скажіть нам.
150 тисяч доларів.
В екскурсії беруть участь переважно українці
та іноземці, що працюють в Києві. Трапляються і
відомі закордонні гості, як-от німецька
євродепутатка Ребекка Гармс.
Добре, що в Україні нарешті є незалежні інституції,
які боряться з корупцією, такі як НАБУ, і такі справи,
як електроні декларації депутатів і система
публічних закупівель "Прозоро". Справді є певний
поступ, але його треба продовжувати.
За півтори години хоч і змерзли, утім,
кажуть туристи, екскурсія була того варта.
Цікаво, що всі ці будинки мені відомі, але я
не знала історії, які їх супроводжують. Особливо
зацікавила історія про вертолітний майданчик, бо,
наприклад, президентську резиденцію в Межигір’ї
я вже бачила.
Найбільше мене вразили суми, про які ми говоримо.
Наприклад, те, що великі гроші були витрачені
на покупку швабр.
Тобто це такі базові знання, коли відчуваєш,
що ніби тебе тримають за дурня.
Такі прогулянки планують проводити не лише
в Києві, але й у Харкові, Одесі та Львові. Адже
охочих чимало. Лише на цю екскурсію записалися
близько 60 учасників.